olá
hoje vim falar um pouco sobre consumo
consciente
esse vídeo fala um pouco sobre meu
projeto
por volta dessa teia sample bar nos
acidentes
ele diz que a gente não precisa de tudo
e só dele é necessário que o que é
consumo consciente consumo consciente é
uma prática que fazemos no nosso dia a
dia quando adquirimos 10 um recurso
utilizamos o recurso da natureza fazer
isso de forma consciente é consumir de
corresponsabilidade porque temos que
consumir de forma consciente porque
nossas atitudes produzindo efeito no
ambiente em que vivemos é que forma
podemos e devemos agir quanto aos
recursos naturais tomando banho a gente
precisa desligar o chuveiro enquanto se
ensaboa escovar os dentes tem que
desligar a torneira
temos que apagar as luzes dos ambientes
que não estamos usando desligar os
eletrodomésticos da tomada e dar carona
para links nesse caso eu vou dar um
exemplo para você entender um pouco
melhor
eu vou para uma festinha sala toda foi
convidada
eu posso levar o amigo que foi convidado
ou eu posso usar o transporte público
que gasta me mesmo poluindo como carro
ele gasta um pouco menos porque o
transporte público usamos é melhor
porque vai várias pessoas dentro dele
mesmo local ou parando antes
quanto aos produtos e bens
industrializados
a gente tem que doar as roupas que não
servem mais sapatos e brinquedos
não é dia para o mercado temos que fazer
uma lista para não cobertas por impulso
quando a gente vai comprar uma roupa
temos que comprar o necessário
você sabia que usaram arquivos vitor
virtuais é melhor do que usar o papel
então é esse aí eu vou explicar porque o
papel vem da árvore e se a gente cortar
as árvores a gente pode nós mesmos
podemos fazer nós mesmos podemos nos
prejudicar porque é da árvore que a
gente respira e reciclando o lixo
nós podemos também economizando algumas
perguntas para o consumo consciente é o
posso eu tenho dinheiro eu vou ficar
endividado o que comprar
como comprar
eu conheço o fabricante terá que
respeitar seus funcionários e utiliza
recursos da natureza vou dar um exemplo
na fábrica de papel é será que ele pede
autorização para o governo e também será
que depois que ele corta as árvores ele
e planta será que depois que utilizará
esse produto eu consigo reutilizar
aplicando conjunto dos erres para o
consumo consciente
aqui os três é isso reduzir quando
utilizar hoje qual é mas como nós
falamos sobre o consumo eu coloquei o
repensar porque a nossa vida está ao
redor de uma palavra repensar nós temos
que pensar antes de fazer qualquer coisa
obrigado pela sua atenção